[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAJA LOGANATHAN: Welcome, all.
I hope you're having a
good time in the conference
while learning from each other.
It's exciting to
me and talk to you
through the booths
and one-on-one events,
learning about new use
cases and new framing
of problems every day.
I am Raja Loganathan.
I'm an engineering manager
with Google Cloud Storage.
I have Sebastian and Frank
from Google Cloud as well.
We also have Sai from one of
our storage partners, Cohesity.
Today, I'd like to talk
about building systems that
have security by
design and default
using Google Cloud Storage.
We work with a lot of customers
from different market segments,
so I would like
that take some time
to talk about the
industry trend that we
see with security and storage.
One of the main themes that
you would have been hearing
through this
conference is how cloud
is democratizing the
special powers for engineers
in our industry.
You don't have to be one
of those few companies
in the world who get to use
a storage system with 11
nines of durability.
Irrespective of whether you're
a startup or a big enterprise
company, you have access
to such a storage system
if that's what you need to
make your business successful.
So today, let's explore
this theme a little bit more
in the context of
security and scalability.
To make my case, I would like
to start off with an analogy.
As many of you might know,
this is Jacques Cousteau.
He pioneered the modern-day
marine conservation.
He has traveled to the
remote corners of the earth
to study coral reef
system and other sea life.
And in order to
be underwater, he
co-developed the first
open circuit breathing
apparatus that evolved into
the modern-day regulators.
He has a tremendous
influence in this field.
Well, thanks to his influence,
I picked up diving as my hobby,
and diving took me to
different parts of the world.
Here is a map of many
of the coral reefs
where I have spent days diving.
Many of these reefs are
in pristine condition,
teeming with life.
Now, let me step back.
I didn't have to be
a Jacques Cousteau
or a full-time marine
researcher to experience
these amazing sights and feel
that sense of appreciation.
What is making it possible
for a common man like me?
Number one, we have
resilient regulators.
They are those that I
can put it in my garage,
and I can use it when I need it.
Number two, no matter which
corner of the earth I go,
there are universal
safety standards.
Even in today's world, diving
can be pretty dangerous,
if not for those
safety standards.
Number three-- this
is more important-- we
have reached a critical mass
of community to support diving.
When you think
about our industry,
we have a similar
trend going on.
You have access to a planet
scale blob storage system.
And as I have been
saying, it provides
11 nines of durability.
Whether you want to
store your few MB photo
or if you are an animation
movie studio wanting
to store terabytes of movie
file, you can store it here.
You can store exabytes of data.
If you're thinking about cost,
we have a range of options,
from hot to cold storage.
If you are streaming music,
the time to first byte
is going to be in milliseconds.
And even if it is
a cold storage,
the response time is going
to be in milliseconds,
as opposed to hours or days.
Here are some of
our customers on how
they use Google Cloud Storage.
Customers use multi-regional
options for content storage
and delivery, and customers
go with the regional option
for big data analytics.
And customers use
near line or co-line
for backup archival purposes.
We also have storage
partners, such as Cohesity,
who offer Google Cloud
Storage as one of the options.
Let me go back to the
scalability theme.
When you're thinking about
the theory of constraints
for your business,
you're no longer
worried about building some
complex distributed system.
Now the focus has shifted to
architecting the right system
for your business.
So let me ask all
of you a question.
For the systems that you're
running for your business,
from a scalability standpoint,
what are the trade offs
you are making?
What failure modes
are you worried about?
What bottlenecks are
you worried about?
Now, I know most
of you are going
to give me a good
set of answers,
because as an
industry, we have done
an effective job
in disseminating
scalability patterns.
And thanks to cloud,
the cognitive load
to think about these patterns
are also substantially less.
Now, start thinking
about security.
I will get to it in a second.
We are seeing example where
within a company, two teams
going with completely
different architecture
with different storage solution.
This was almost
unimaginable 10, 15
years, when your organization
picked one storage
solution or the other.
Effectively, our
organization and our systems
are becoming a starfish.
Starfish has this
interesting neural structure
where if it loses an arm,
it's going to regrow it.
In fact, starfish can shed
an arm as a defense mechanism
because it knows it can regrow.
So what about security?
With security, what
we're seeing is
we are still stuck in
the traditional model
of having a single watchdog team
for your entire organization.
With the pace of innovation,
the velocity of changes
that are going on and the
sheer complexity of the systems
that you're running--
by the way, the complexity
is not going to go down.
Having this relational
model is just not scalable.
Our organizations
and our systems
have to become a starfish from
a security standpoint, as well.
We have to emulate
the success that we
have created with scalability.
Security is the new scalability.
So in order to effectively
disseminate security ideas,
patterns are a
very good mechanism
for you to have good
conversations with your team
to make intentional choices and
build security at every layer.
So in the next few
slides, let's talk
about some of the
security patterns
that we commonly see
among our customers,
The first thing with
security is people.
When you're thinking
of scalability,
we mostly think in
terms of systems.
But with security, people
play an equal role.
As I've been saying, with
a growing complexity,
there are often
interesting interplay
between people and system.
So for you to have
good security,
there has to be
intentional architecting
for people and system.
To talk about the next
couple of patterns,
let me set up a scenario.
Let's say you're a financial
company with multiple research
teams.
Let's say these research teams
are operating on a common data
set.
The data set is
particularly not sensitive.
Let's say it's a
public data set.
But the results being
produced by your research team
is what is providing you
the competitive advantage
in the market.
They are extremely sensitive
that you don't even want
to share among other teams.
And let's say you also
have a team of analysts
who are looking at these
results to make decisions
on behalf of your business.
So using that scenario, let's
talk about this first pattern.
This is the confused
deputy pattern.
This is the case when there
is an ambiguous definition
of responsibility or authority.
So in our scenario,
let's say the researcher
found some interesting
results and want
to share with his team.
He can go to our Google
Cloud Storage console
and hit the Share
Publicly button
to provide reader
access to his team.
But that action is not only
providing reader access
to his organization or his team.
He is providing reader access
to the entire public internet.
So this is not even
a bad actor scenario.
This is a good actor
with good intentions,
but still, the consequences
are not what you desire.
By the way, we are revamping
this console experience, too,
to make it better.
So to tactically
solve the problem,
the first thing you
have to take care
is you have to define the roles.
We have predefined
roles, for example,
in this scenario
for the researcher.
Maybe you can go with
a creator role, where
they can create objects but not
necessarily modify permissions.
If you're not happy with
the predefined roles,
we have IAM custom
roles that you
can create with a customized
set of permissions.
But still, this is too
contextual, too tactical.
There are a lot of
storage permissions,
as you can see here.
So is there a way to
solve this problem
at a higher granularity?
So let's talk about this next
pattern, privilege separation
pattern.
Let's say you are using
Google KMS to encrypt data
in cloud storage.
Now you have two
sets of permissions
that you can operate with.
For example, analysts
at a higher granularity
can think about which
projects have which access.
So now no matter what the
storage permissions are,
people cannot read the object
without the decrypt permission.
Let's zoom out even further.
If you set up a virtual private
network across your resources
in Google Cloud across your
buckets, objects, Google
Compute Engine other
services, now irrespective
any permission,
none of that data
is going to get out of that
perimeter that you have set up.
All right, let's switch gears.
Let's talk about some
encryption patterns.
The first one is the
key wrapping pattern.
This is super useful to solve
encryption problem at scale,
and to solve problems
like pseudo anonymization
for sensitive information,
such as credit card number.
To illustrate this
example, I would
like to use an example from
within our system on how
we use this pattern inside
of Google Cloud storage.
Let's say you use KMS to store
an object in our servers.
When we get the object,
the first thing we do
is chunk them.
This is to make sure we use our
own infrastructure effectively.
The main approach here is going
to be take all of those chunks,
send it over to the
KMS, get it encrypted,
get it back, and
then store them.
It is pretty
ineffective, because
of the data going all around.
And from a performance
profile, it's
not going to be
acceptable for you.
Instead, what we do is we
generate a local encryption key
for each one of those chunks.
And then after
encrypting the chunks,
we take those local encryption
key, send it over to KMS,
get it encrypted, get it
back, and then store it
in our system, which effectively
achieves the same purpose.
You could also use this example
for the [INAUDIBLE] station
let's say you are
storing files in cloud
storage with
sensitive information,
such as social security
number, credit card number.
Instead of sending the
whole file over to KMS,
you could use a
local encryption key
to anonymize those information
and then send that local key
over to KMS, get it encrypted.
Let's talk about this next
pattern, crypto shredding
pattern.
In order to provide the best
possible customer experience,
you're trying to solve
all kinds of cool problems
for your customers.
Let's say you take the
data stored in your bucket,
move it to BigQuery
to do some analytics,
then take the data
further to do some more
analysis to provide
that additional value
for your customer.
But what is happening
is the customer
data is getting proliferated.
When the time comes
to deletion, you
want to effectively delete
the entire footprint
to maintain trust
with your customer,
and sometimes to meet
regulations like GDPR.
So in such scenarios,
this pattern
could potentially be useful.
Let's say you're
using Google KMS.
You can use the same key across
different Google services.
Now, as soon as you get rid of
the key, then all of the data
are effectively meaningless.
And then you can go around
cleaning them up later.
But from a customer
point of view,
you have effectively
deleted the data.
We are after similar approach
within Google Cloud Storage,
too.
The first thing we focus on is
getting rid of those encryption
keys to make all of
those chunks meaningless.
And then we go to the
garbage collection.
The last pattern I
want to talk about
is the privilege
revocation pattern.
In the previous pattern,
we talked about how
to effectively delete the data.
In this pattern,
let's talk about how
to effectively not
delete the data.
I'm not joking here.
There are valid scenarios.
Let's say you're a
financial industry.
Then you're required
to keep some data
for x number of years.
In those cases, you can
basically revoke access
from a deletion standpoint.
And then, no matter who you
are in your organization,
you can't delete the data.
Google Cloud will keep it
for the x number of years
that you have
specified, and then it
will open up the access back to
you so that you can delete it.
By the way, that image
over there is not a jail--
before your
imaginations run wild.
That's Fort Knox, where
the gold is stored.
Next, I would like to invite
Subhasish to talk about the GCS
security primitives
that you get.
SUBHASISH CHAKRABORTY:
So as Raja said, security
is the new scalability.
Security is something which
is at the heart of our design,
as far as GCS in particular
and Google Cloud platform
in general is concerned.
Security is not
something that we
think of something that can
be an afterthought, that you
can bolt on later.
It is something that you
have to plan for and design
at every layer of your stack.
So when our users use
Google Cloud Storage,
or in general when
they use Google Cloud,
there are lots of special
powers with regards
to security that they get.
So according to third
party estimates,
Google's private
network is probably
the largest private network
out there in the world.
It has thousands of Edge nodes.
It has hundreds of POP nodes.
As a customer, you
are never too far away
from a Google point of presence.
Now, this is a tremendous
security advantage
for our customers, as well.
So what happens
is, say your data
is stored in a
particular region,
but you are accessing the
data from a different city
or you are writing to the
data from a different city.
Now, with any other
cloud storage provider
out there, what would
happen is the data
would take the public
internet to the region
where the data is stored.
With GCS, what
happens is we actually
get your data through
the nearest POP.
So say if you're writing
from New York City,
we'll actually get the data
into Google's private network
through the POP
in New York City.
And you might be actually
writing your data to Europe.
So this has tremendous benefits
in terms of performance.
It has tremendous
benefits in terms of cost,
because you are not
paying egress charges
for public internet travel.
But most importantly, this
has also tremendous benefit
in terms of security.
Because what happens
is, your data
is traversing through the
private network of Google
for as much time as
possible, thereby minimizing
exposure in public internet.
Now, encryption
is something which
is at the core of security
considerations, as well.
So with GCS, all your
data is always encrypted.
We have multiple layers of
encryption for GCS data.
Your data is encrypted
at the data layer.
It is encrypted at the
storage and media layer.
There are some public
cloud storage providers
with whom default
encryption is an option.
We fundamentally
don't believe in that.
Personally speaking,
I find this sentence,
where you have default
encryption option,
it seems to me an
oxymoronic statement.
So we fundamentally
believe, as a platform,
that all your data should
always be encrypted.
Now, encryption at rest is fine.
What about encryption in flight?
All of your GCS data is
also encrypted in flight.
The only exceptions we have
are for multi-cloud use
cases, where you might be
writing to another cloud
storage which is not encrypted
by default. For example,
for [INAUDIBLE]
compatibility, we
do support unencrypted modes
of data movement in flight.
But for all of your
native GCS data,
it is always
encrypted in flight.
Now, in addition to encryption,
what is also very important
is, how do you manage
the encryption?
How do you actually
manage the keys
which are encrypting your data?
So I often talk
to some customers
from highly regulated
industries with a high security
sensitivity.
They say, you know, Subhasish,
everything you say is great,
but I cannot really store
my encryption key with you.
My dictates are such that I
need to store the encryption key
on my premises or on my HSM.
So GCS allows for that as well.
You do not have to store
your encryption keys with us.
You just supply to us during
the time you write the data
or you read the data or you
do any metadata operation.
So we fully support
customer-supplied encryption
key, as well.
So along with encryption,
another very key component
of your security
considerations is auditing.
For regulatory compliance,
auditing is very important.
For even you-- for
regulatory compliance even
from your perspective,
if you have
to ensure things are working
the way they are supposed to,
and access is the way it is,
you need to ensure that you
have solid audits in place.
So as a platform
and as a product,
we believe in giving
you a lot of choice.
So with GCS, as far as
auditing is concerned,
you can go for
multiple options here.
You can go for
Cloud Audit Logging,
which is a platform-wide
logging capability.
So whether it is
administrative activity
or it is data access
audit logging,
you can get it through
Cloud Audit Logging.
Now, if you want
to really dig deep
and you want to find
out at a very fine
granularity that per object--
what's the kind of
latency I'm getting?
What is the kind of data
storage patterns that I have?
Or how is my object
lifecycle management behaving
per object level?
If you are interested
in that kind of detail,
then you can also go for
GCS Access and Storage Logs.
And then finally,
from a compliance
and regulatory perspective, if
you want to consume these logs
and if you want to pipe them
into your pipelines, your audit
systems, deployment
architectures,
you can use
Stackdriver Monitoring,
which gives you programmatic
access to this audit logging
information, as well.
So again, in many conversations
when I travel across the world
and I speak to new
customers or prospects,
they asked me, [INAUDIBLE]
Subhasish, all that is great,
but I come from
health care industry.
Unless you talk HIPAA-- unless
you are HIPAA compliant--
I can't really use you.
So not only we are HIPPA
compliant, as you can see,
we are a platform with
rich third-party audits
and certifications.
We are SOC compliant.
We are ISO compliant.
We are PCI level
three compliant.
And we are FedRAMP ATO
compliant, as well.
So we are an
enterprise platform,
and we take care of the fact
that whatever level of auditing
and certification you need to
be with us, it will be there.
So in today's world,
PII, or Personally
Identifiable Information, is a
very important topic right now.
It's very topical because
it's very sensitive in nature.
And it's the center stone.
So PII, or personally
identifiable information,
is the center stone around
which a lot of regulations
such as GDPR is formulated.
So GDPR is live
even as we speak.
There are several
other regulations
which are also in
the process of being
formulated, which all center
around, how do you handle PII?
So in our platform, we have
data loss prevention APIs--
DLP-- which allows you
to effectively redact,
encrypt, pseudo-anonymize.
And for you to get a very
good grip on how your PII is.
So it allows you to
analyze your PII.
It allows you to
visualize your PII
and effectively manage your PII.
So one customer use
case that I can share
with you is the following.
So say you are a financial
organization or you are a bank
and you want to ingest your
data into GCS as a data lake.
And you want to run
big data analytics,
and you want to understand
analytic patterns
for your data.
But the challenge that you face
working with a public cloud
is, what do I do with my PII?
Because there might be so
many credit card information--
first name, last name, email
ID, age, social security number,
and so on.
So this is where DLP
comes into place.
You ingest your data in GCS.
You run DLP over it.
DLP completely
pseudo-anonymizes,
redacts all the data.
And then you can actually
go ahead with BigQuery,
and you can analyze the data.
And when the time comes and
you want to pipe the data out
of the system and move
it back to, say, on prem,
you can use DLP to
encrypt data as it
egresses the public cloud.
So this allows you to
completely leverage
the power of Google Cloud,
and at the same time,
ensure that you do not sacrifice
or compromise your PII at all.
So these are all the
existing special powers
that Google Cloud as a platform
and cloud storage as a product
gives you.
But that's not all we are
here to speak about today.
It gives me a lot of joy to
talk about the new features
that we are announcing
here publicly today.
For the whole last
year or so, our team
has been busy working
with our customers
to closely understand the
problems that they face,
and really solve
high-level problems so
that we can continue to work
effectively in this new world.
The first feature I
want to announce today
is access transparency with GCS.
This integration is going
general availability.
And this should be available
for general public consumption
pretty soon, maybe as soon as
this event is over-- maybe as
soon as next week.
So with access transparency,
the main problem
that we are solving
is if you want
to know who it is that
has access to your data.
So this "who" could be
a Googler who's SRE.
And the SRE might have
access to your data
because, say, a hurricane
was headed towards your data
center.
Or maybe you raised a
ticket and you said, hey,
I want you to move this data
from this location to that
because this sets me up
for better performance.
Now, from a compliance and a
regulatory perspective, what
you want to have is a very
clean trail of who has accessed
my data, what is the location
from which this data has been
accessed, who is
this person, why
has this person moved my data--
what is the justification?
So access transparency gives
you all this information.
And it is also available through
Stackdriver Monitoring for you
to programmatically
integrate with your systems.
The second feature that I am
announcing today is going GA.
And this is, again, a feature
which will be available
probably as soon as next week.
We are actually in the
process of rolling out
the GA changes for this.
It's a bunch of security
and privacy UI enhancements.
And to tell you the problem
why we're doing this--
so over last year,
last year and a half,
across different
public cloud services,
we heard from our
customers who are
using some of the services that
said that one problem that they
faced is, they didn't have a
very good handle on what part
of their data is public and
what part of their datasets
are private.
So inadvertently, they ended
up over-exposing their data.
And in some cases, they
were taken hostage of,
because the sharing model
was not really very safe.
There are various solutions
with Google Cloud Platform
that you don't run into
this kind of a problem.
Like VPC is a major step
towards the direction.
But you might say,
you know what, VPC
is a big sledgehammer for me.
I don't want to use VPC.
Can you give me
something simpler?
So we are doing
this UI enhancement,
where in your GCS browser,
you can very clearly see
which of your buckets are
public, which of your objects
are public.
And like the confused
deputy access pattern
that Raja mentioned,
where you could
be sharing the data
publicly, thinking public
means your company publicly,
not public internet.
So with these new
UI changes, even
if you are under a wrong
impression as to what
your blast radius
was, you can't really
do this, because we now have
a IAM panel-based interaction.
And through this IAM
panel-based interaction,
you would be setting
permissions on your data sets.
So there is absolutely
no way that, by accident
or inadvertently,
you would be sharing
this data with public internet.
The third feature I'm announcing
today publicly is Cloud KMS.
Some of you-- some
of GCS customers
are actually testing
this even as we speak,
because this is in public beta.
What Cloud KMS
gives, to describe
what is the common problem that
we hear from our customers,
is they want fine granular
manageability of their keys.
Like, I should be able to
create my key, delete me key,
rotate my key.
I should be able to
set automatic rotation
schedule for my key.
I should be able
to disable the key.
And so on.
But the main challenge they
face is hosting a key management
service and assuring
that the key management
service is always on, is
very highly available.
It can be very challenging.
Like what happens due
to hardware failure
or due to some error?
You actually lose
an encryption key.
You might actually lose access
to petabytes of information.
So what Cloud KMS does for
you is, with Cloud KMS,
Google hosts the key for you.
Google ensures that the key
is always available for you,
in every single region, with
the latency and availability
that you want.
But you still retain
all the ability
to have very fine granular
management for your encryption
keys.
And with this GCS
integration, you
get the same [INAUDIBLE]
in terms of availability
and durability and performance
that is there with GCS, even
if you did not use Cloud KMS.
Because as I said, all the data
in GCS is always encrypted.
Either you use Cloud KMS and
manage the keys yourself,
or Google would automatically
manage it for you.
So Cloud KMS is in
public beta right now.
I invite you guys to
actually test it out.
And as with all other
features, Cloud KMS
is also available
programmatically.
Now, we briefly
alluded to VPC before.
VPC was a very highly requested
feature for quite a long time.
A lot of customers were used
to sharing patterns and network
firewalls in their
private infrastructure.
But the challenge with
public cloud they faced
is, the moment they
come to public cloud,
their existing sharing patterns
may be a little riskier.
So what VPC allows you to do
is to have a network a firewall
and for you to have
an environment as
if you have your own private
cloud within public cloud.
So with VPC, you say, this
is my security access zone--
this is my secure
access zone, rather.
And in this secure access
zone, I put a few services.
Like, you can say, these
are my GC instances.
This is my GCS service.
And this is my BigQuery.
And these are the
services which should
be able to talk to each other.
By doing this, you ensure that
your data cannot be exfiltrated
to any other service.
Additionally, what you can
also do is, you can say,
these are the
on-prem IP addresses
which I'm whitelisting.
So this extends the
hybrid security access
patterns to the public cloud
and gives you your own firewall.
So this is a very, very
strong security primitive.
We are announcing private
beta for VPC service controls,
and we invite you
to test this feature
and get a chance to shape it
as it goes into production, GA.
So last but not the least,
today's the first time--
it gives me a lot
of joy that this
is the first time
we are announcing
Bucket Lock, an early-access
program for GCS customers.
So what Bucket Lock is is
basically WORM storage.
WORM stands for Write
Once, Read Many times.
It is also traditionally,
classically,
called retention lock.
So the use case is this.
Say you are a finance company.
You have to conform to FINRA,
SEC, or CFTC regulation.
Or you are in movie
archive business,
or you are doing general
backup and archive.
And you need to ensure
that all your data has
a certain retention.
So once I write data, say your
retention length is five years.
And once you have set
that retention period,
during this five
years, it should not
be possible for
anybody, including me,
to delete this data or
to modify this data.
WORM storage is the solution
for this kind of a use case.
With GCS's Bucket Lock, it
applies across all our storage
classes.
Unlike other cloud
services out there,
it's not just for our
coldest storage tier.
You can use Bucket Lock across
any storage tier in GCS.
And you can use the same APIs.
We are just introducing
two new operations.
One is set retention policy.
The second is lock
the retention policy.
But that's it.
You can use all the
existing, new APIs.
And in addition to the basic,
fundamental WORM capabilities,
we also supporting
temporary hold and event
hold, which are a little
more advanced features.
I'll give you a couple
of small examples.
Temporary hold example is, say
your company is getting audited
for two weeks or three weeks.
Only during that time, you
want to ensure that you
have retention locks set.
That is your use case
for temporary hold.
An event-based
hold example would
be, say you are a company who's
in the business of selling
mortgages or loans.
So you want to let the mortgage
period or the loan period
play out.
And after that, for
FINRA, you still
want to hold onto that
client's mortgage.
It goes for another five years.
This is an example
of event-based hold.
So I would invite all of you to
test out this feature, as well.
And with that, I would invite
my friend Frank to give you guys
a demo for these new features.
FRANK NATIVIDAD:
Thanks, Subhasish.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Frank.
I am an engineer in
developer relations
that focuses on Google Cloud
Storage developer experience.
Today, I'll be covering
three special powers
that Google Cloud
Platform provides you.
And to give this
demo context, I'd
like you to take a
look at this slide.
So I'm working with
this fictional financial
institution.
And they have a
credit card support
team that has a chat support.
Those chat support
conversation logs
are then stored into
Google Cloud Storage.
So with this context,
let's jump in.
Can we switch to
the demo, please?
Thank you.
So the first special
power I want to talk about
is, let's say that you--
or at least for
this demo, we want
to manage the lifecycle
of the encryption keys
that are used for the objects
or the conversations that
are logged within this bucket.
So what we're going to
take a look at first
is customer-managed
encryption keys.
To get started, we need
to create a new KMS key.
So to do that, we
need to create a key.
So I'm going to name it "credit
card support team key ring."
This will hold the key.
And I'll select a
Location of us-central1.
Click Create.
Next, I'll create the key.
Similar name--
"support-team-key."
And the rotation period is how
often a new version of this key
is created.
I'll keep these as default
for now and click Create.
Cool.
So we have created a KMS key.
So next, we're going
to create our GCS
bucket using this key for a
customer-managed encryption
key.
So let's go over to the
Google Cloud Storage browser.
Click Create Bucket.
So I'm going to follow
a similar pattern--
"credit-card-support-team-logs."
And I'm going to select
a regional location.
At this time, you must
co-locate your KMS key ring
and your GCS bucket.
So I'm also going to
select us-central1.
Below, you'll notice that we've
added Show Advanced Settings.
We have, by default,
Google-managed keys.
But I'm going to use
customer-managed keys
for this demo.
A new dropdown shows up.
I can now select the KMS
key that I just created.
And a little message pops up.
This tells me that GCS does not
have the necessary permissions
to act on our behalf to use this
KMS key to encrypt and decrypt
objects.
So I'm going to give it
the necessary permissions
by clicking Grant.
And now I can click Create.
I'm going to test upload a
file to see how this all works.
I have here a support
team conversation.
And I'm just going
to upload this.
[INAUDIBLE]
And I click Finish.
Over to the right, you'll
notice that encryption type.
The encryption type is
customer-managed key.
And if you highlight
over that, it
will tell you the information
as to which key is being
used to encrypt this object.
So over the lifecycle
of your bucket,
even if you change the
KMS key that you're using,
you'll always know
which key is being
used to encrypt which object.
So with this special power, one
thing I would like to recall
is Raja mentioning the
pattern crypto shredding.
So let's say that I need to
perform a mass deletion of data
within a short period of time.
This, potentially,
could be a large task,
which may take longer than
the period of time you have
to delete this information.
But now that we have
customer-managed keys,
you can do this
operation by just
doing a crypto shred, which
effectively destroys the KMS
key that's encrypting
these objects,
invalidating the
data that's in GCS.
So let's take a look
at how to do that.
Let's go back to Security,
Cryptographic Keys.
Click that.
In order to do this, I'm going
to "Destroy all key version
material."
That will start that.
And I need to type this in--
copy-paste that, Schedule
Destruction.
The first thing it does
is it disables the key
from being used for future
encryption or decryption.
And the second thing it
does is it schedules it
for destruction.
And it takes about 24 hours
for that key to be destroyed.
Let's go back to the GCS bucket.
So now that we've disabled the
key, what we can now do is--
I'll show you an example,
what happens when you try
to access that object again.
So by accessing
this object, we see
that GCS is no longer able
to decrypt the object.
So we'll show this
error message whenever
you try to attempt
to access the object.
It's "The Cloud KMS key
is disabled or destroyed."
So that's the first
special power.
Moving on to the
second special power.
So let's say I want to
keep these conversations
safe from being deleted
accidentally, or modified
in any way.
The next thing I'm going to
talk about is Bucket Lock.
I'm going to cover a brief
preview of the UI changes
that are coming to the storage
browser in order for you
to set a retention
policy for your bucket.
As you can see, there
will be a new tab
for the retention policy.
And I can now set
a retention policy
within certain
different units of time.
I'm going to use seconds
for the sake of this demo,
and set it to 10 seconds.
Click Save.
Two new lines come up.
The lock state is unlocked, so
I can still modify and remove
this retention policy.
And the effective time is
when this policy took effect.
Let's go over, back
to the objects,
and I'll try to upload
the same conversation
that we did before.
Close that.
And I will try to delete it
before 10 seconds are up.
All right, cool.
So as you can see
here, it's forbidden,
that I cannot delete
this object at this time.
So Bucket Lock has removed
the necessary permissions
that I need in order
to delete this object.
After 10 seconds,
or the time frame
that you've set in
this retention policy,
you should be able to delete it.
And you can automate
this process
with Object Lifecycle
Management if you wish to do so.
And then the last
thing I want to cover
is the last special power.
So these conversations that
are held with this credit card
support team, they need
to verify the customer
that they're speaking with.
So there's most likely
PII in this conversation.
But for all intents
and purposes,
you're most likely going to--
or at least, we're just going
to use it for quality assurance,
just to make sure
the customer's happy.
And we don't need
that PII to verify
that the customer is happy.
So I'm going to
cover a DLP demo.
So let's take a look at this,
the short little conversation
here.
As you can see, it's between a
customer and a customer support
team member.
As I scroll down
some more, you'll
notice that a lot more PII
was provided than necessary
to verify this customer.
So we'd like to use a
data loss prevention
API to go ahead and
redact this information.
So I'm going to
click End Chat, which
will then start the process.
That happens, sometimes.
So I have this new one.
So you can see,
over to your right,
it has redacted the PII
from the conversation, which
then can be stored in GCS.
As you can see, it does
it for images, as well.
With that, can we switch
back to the slides, please?
Thank you.
With that, I would like
to invite Subhasish
back up to the stage to hear
from one of our partners.
Thank you.
SUBHASISH CHAKRABORTY:
Thanks, Frank.
[APPLAUSE]
So I invite all of
you to participate
in various stages of--
sorry.
So with that, I
invite all of you
to participate in various
stages of testing,
whether it's beta
or early access,
and try out these
features, and get a chance
to shape how these features
turn out during the GA time.
With that, I would
like to introduce
my friend Sai, who is from
product management at Cohesity.
He will talk about his
experiences of partnering
with Google Cloud
Storage, and also
share with you experiences
from his own customers
using Google Cloud Storage.
Sai.
SAI KRISHNA MUKUNDAN:
Thanks, Subhasish.
So first of all,
thanks to the Google
team for extending an invite
to be part of this session.
Really excited to be here.
So like Subhasish said,
I'm from Cohesity.
I'm in the product
management team there.
And over the next
several minutes,
what I'm going to try and cover
is give you a little bit sense
of how Google Cloud Storage
and Cohesity partner together,
but more importantly,
also talk about it
in the context of a
real customer example,
in terms of how they integrate
both Cohesity and GCS.
So with that, just
a quick background
in terms of what
Cohesity's about.
So Cohesity is a
technology startup
right here in Silicon
Valley, and with the mission
of redefining what we
call a secondary storage.
So if you look at
just data in general,
you have, obviously, your
mission-critical primary
environments.
But what we see is, there is
a lot more growth in what we
refer to as secondary storage.
And that refers to backup,
test dev, disaster recovery,
because of the fact that
for every primary dataset,
there are multiple copies of
that data that exists today
with the incumbent solutions.
So the first challenge
that we have with customers
is in the aspect of
backup and recovery,
which is referred to
as data protection.
That's where the Cohesity-Google
partnership really
comes into play.
So what you see here
is, on the left,
we have the Cohesity data
platform, as we call it,
which is a scale-out on-premise
solution, in this case,
that can integrate seamlessly
with Google Cloud Storage--
with any class of Google Cloud
Storage, as a matter of fact,
whether it's regional,
multi-regional, nearline,
and coldline, as well.
So the idea here is,
with the data platform
that we have on
premise, customers
can then easily set policies.
And again, everything that we
do is policy-based, API-driven
architecture.
So customers can set policies
to manage their backups,
retention policies, and
then extend it to leverage
the GCS offering for
really long-term retention.
So what you see here
is, in this example,
customers typically back
up the data on premise.
And then the policies
will seamlessly
move that data into GCS.
and.
In this case, Cohesity manages
that retention both on premise
as well as in Google Cloud.
To extend this a
little bit, we also
have an offering which we can
run within the GCP platform.
And we call that the Cohesity
Data Platform Cloud Edition.
So like Subhasish
alluded to, more and more
workloads are also born
in the cloud these days.
And so backup data recovery
and data protection
becomes a critical aspect of it,
not only for your on premise,
but also within the
workloads running in GCP.
So that's where Cloud
Edition comes into play.
So in a similar
vein, you can now
set up policies to back up
your infrastructure running
in GCP onto the Cloud
Edition platform.
And that Cloud
Edition actually runs
on the compute
infrastructure, GCE.
It uses persistent disks.
And then GCS can be an extension
of those persistent disks that
are there in the Google Cloud.
The benefits to
customers in general,
I would say broadly
three things.
One is the simplicity
and ease of use
that we bring to the table in
terms of backup and recovery.
The second is the
scalability of the solutions.
So obviously, when we are
talking the scale of GCP,
then the offering that we have
also needs to be scalable.
So that's the second
aspect of it--
the fact that we can scale
both on premise as well
as in the cloud with more
of a pay-as-you-grow model.
As your needs grow, you can
keep adding more and more
of the Cohesity solution.
And last but not
least is the security.
The fact that we can
leverage the encryption
that Google offers, and then
when it's on premise, the data
is again encrypted,
and in flight as well.
And then tying it in
with the VPC elements
that Subhasish brought up.
So in order to do
that, let me actually
illustrate that with a real
customer example with one
of our mutual customers.
So this is a large semiconductor
manufacturer right here,
actually, in the Bay Area.
And their use case
is broadly twofold.
One is, they continue to have
more of a hybrid environment--
some on premise, as well
as new workloads in GCP.
And they're looking
for a data protection
offering that can do both
while also leveraging GCS.
So what they started off
with is, deploy the Cohesity
platform on premise.
And in fact, they
have grown that
over the last several months.
And then for the
long-term retention,
send the data on a
policy-based schedule
to Google Cloud Storage.
So that's where
they started with.
As an extension for their
workloads running within GCP,
they are now using our
data platform Cloud Edition
in a VPC that's been defined.
And the reason they leverage
the VPC and IAM concepts
that Raja talked about is they
have several different projects
within GCP--
basically, various different
teams, and also acquisitions
that have happened
over time, resulting
in a number of GCP projects.
So they manage all this
through the VPC and IAM roles.
And in the backup
recovery context,
IAM roles are even
more significant,
because in terms of managing
just the administrative tasks,
you can have one role.
But in order to provide
self-service capability back
to the end users, you want
them to have the ability
to recover their virtual
machines, their files.
And so there are
various different roles
created in order to facilitate
self-service recovery, as well.
So again, it ties in back
to the VPC and IAM security
constructs.
And the last element
I will add is,
we're also excited to be a
technology partner with Google
on the Bucket Lock aspect.
This is something that
not only this customer
is looking for, but also
several of our mutual customers.
So we are excited to be
playing a role in that.
And it directly ties in well
with, again, the retention use
case.
Now, they can not only
manage the retention aspects
both within Cohesity
as well as GCS,
but customers can now leverage
the WORM functionality
to comply with legal hold and
other compliance regulations.
So with that, again,
great to be here.
We have a booth here at Next.
So please visit our booth
for more information.
And thanks for
having us, Subhasish.
SUBHASISH CHAKRABORTY:
Thanks, Sai.
[APPLAUSE]
So to conclude, I would like
to reiterate that security
is at the heart of our design.
You can see it from
the amount of engineers
we have dedicated to security,
the amount of investment we
do for security, the amount of
cutting-edge research papers
which are coming out
of Google every year,
and the number of
custom silicons
we are innovating every year
in the field of security
to ensure that your data
is indeed safe with Google.
So security is something
we take very seriously.
As Diane mentioned, security
is the number one worry
for our customers who are
moving to public cloud.
We want to ensure, with Google,
it's not a worry anymore.
As you witnessed it
in our session today,
we are continuing to innovate.
And along with all the special
powers we have at this point
and all the new features
we continue to build,
we are giving you every
single tool and feature
you need to have
systems which are
secure by design and default.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]